-Here's what people
are talking about.
Some big political news.
Today President Trump
went on Twitter and announced
that he is banning
transgender people
from serving in the military.
[ Audience boos ]
This guy.
Trump said he understands
this is a very sensitive issue,
so he made sure to choose
his emojis very carefully.
Uh...
[ Applause ]
Actually, Trump says that
he's banning transgender people
from serving because
of high medical costs.
If he cares so much
about high medical costs,
maybe he should pass
a health-care bill.
Come on. What is he...
If he cares so much --
My God.
And Trump was talking
to reporters yesterday
after the big health-care vote,
and people noticed
that he didn't seem to know
how many senators there are.
When told it's two
for each state, Trump said,
"I'm going to need
another clue.
I -- 15?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course, another big story
is Trump's feud
with Attorney General
Jeff Sessions.
And when he was asked
what will happen to Sessions,
Trump said, "Time will tell."
When asked if he was
just stealing lines
if his Magic 8-Ball,
Trump said, "Ask again later."
No. Wait. This is all...
[ Applause ]
-Whoa.
-Meanwhile
the State Department says
Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson is
"taking a little time off."
Wow. Tillerson, Spicer,
maybe Sessions.
You know things are bad
when the White House
is losing more characters
than "Game of Thrones."
You know,
this is a lot of people.
[ Applause ]
And Trump held a big rally
in Ohio last night.
And I saw that
he rubbed Melania's back
while she was introducing him.
It was the first time
someone has ever shivered
in 80-degree weather.
It is just -- It's kind of warm.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right. Trump gave
a speech in Youngstown, Ohio.
And everyone is talking about
a pretty big comparison
that he made.
Take a look at this.
With the exception
of the late, great
Abraham Lincoln,
I can be more presidential
than any President that's
ever held this office.
That I can tell you.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Audience boos ]
Then he said,
"I won't be, but I can."
[ Laughter and applause ]
After watching Trump's speech,
CNN's Ana Navarro made
a pretty interesting comparison
of her own. Watch this.
Guys, I've never done
hallucinogenic mushrooms,
but when I watch one of
these Trump rally speeches,
I feel, "Okay, this
is what it must be like
to be high on
hallucinogenic mushrooms."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
When Wolf Blitzer heard that,
he was like,
"Just tell me what you need
and how much."
And you go, "Wait. Wait."
And Trump's new communications
director, Anthony Scaramucci,
addressed all the leaks
that have been coming out
and asked staffers, "You want to
sell postcards to the tourists
or you want to work
in the West Wing?"
And the staffers said,
"Wait. Is that postcard thing
a real option or...?
I love postcards."
But as I mentioned earlier,
Trump has decided to ban
transgender people from
serving in the military.
It's very controversial,
so here to address this issue
is "Tonight Show" correspondent
Patti Harrison.
Patti, thank you for joining us.
-Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Now, Jimmy,
I'm a transgender woman.
And as a transperson,
it's hard to articulate
exactly how I feel.
But I guess if I had to
describe it, I'd say,
"Donald, you're so stupid.
You are so stupid.
You're lucky you're so hot."
-Wait a second.
[ Laughs ]
"Lucky you're so hot."
Patti, when did you first hear
about Trump's decision?
-Well, when I saw
the headline this morning,
at first, I just read,
"Donald Trump bans
transgender people."
And I was like,
"Yeah, that sounds like him."
But then I realized
it was just in the military,
and I was shocked because
I assumed he already did that.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I don't necessarily want
to serve in the military,
but I want the right to serve.
You know, it's like I don't
want to go to your baby shower,
but I want the invite.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know,
I don't even think Trump knows
what transgender means.
He probably thinks
transgender people
are those cars
that turn into robots.
-Yeah. It might be --
It might be so.
Patti, before you go,
do you have any final thoughts
about all of this?
-Well, first, I want to say
that there are amazingly brave
transpeople
who should be allowed to serve,
like Kristin Beck,
a retired Navy SEAL
with a Purple Heart,
Bronze Star,
and countless service medals.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
And yet Trump says transgender
people in the military
would be
a tremendous disruption.
And I get it.
If you constantly
draw attention to yourself,
spend all day
distracting everyone,
and cost taxpayers
millions of dollars,
the perfect job for you
isn't the military.
It's the president
of the United States.
-Thank you very much.
Patti Harrison, everybody.
Thank you, Patti.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"You're lucky you're hot."
That's a -- Yeah, yeah.
Here's a local story,
you guys, here.
The MTA wants to improve
the subway here in New York
by removing seats from trains
to fit more people.
And after that, they're
going to ask riders to lie down
and spoon each other so they
can pack even more inside.
Like, I'll be the inner spoon?
That's right.
The MTA wants to remove seats
from trains to fit more people.
Even worse, Southwest Airlines
heard that and said,
"That's a great idea.
Can we do that?"
And you go, "No.
You can't do that on a plane."
And finally,
I saw that a woman in Texas
bought a $300 vacuum from Target
but got home and realized
the box contained
dirty towels, rocks,
and a can of chili...
or, as that's known over
at Walmart, a gift basket.
There you guys go.
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!